بمرجحوه بمرجحوه له
بعدين بيخزفوا فيها فوق وبيتركوا برتفع
السجان السجين وهو على ظهره
وبيهوي على الارض طبعا هاي العقوبه احيانا
كانت تؤدي للموت
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم متابعينا الكرام اينما كنتم انا
طاهر بركه احييكم واقدم اليكم حلقه جديده
من برنامجكم الذاكره السياسيه نتابع فيها
مع مصطفى خليفه المعتقل السياسي السوري
السابق والروائي الشهير اهلا بكم معنا
استاذ مصطفى مره جديده بعرف ما بتحب كلمه
بطل او شير بس يعني اسمح لنا ان نتبنى هذه
الالقاب اذا اصبح لك سجنان السجان هو
النظام الذي يقمعك ويعذبك والسجان الاخر
اشد وطاه اشد وطن اشد وطن كيف كانت
المعامله في الداخل مقاطعه تامه
مقاطعه تامه يعني
عدم
التعاطي معه لسنوات تصور هذا الموضوع بصير
لسنوات
معزول مكروه
هو ضل 14 سنه بس مو كلها بهذا المعجزه
بتنقل يعني تخففت عليه الامور شوي انه راح
على سجن صيدنايا فتره بعد ما نقلوه من
تدمر وبعدين راح على سجن مدني سجن
تابع للشرطه المدنيه طيب والمقاطعه كانت
عمليا لا صباح الخير ولا مساء الخير حتى
الى هذا الكلام ولا كلام يعني بالفترات
الاخيره يعني خفت قليلا من خلال
بعض الناس اللي كانوا دارسين في فرنسا
يعني صار في معرفه نسيم ومجموعه من
الاطباء شخصيه اساسيه ايضا
وقت اللي عرف انه هذا وبعدين صار وبعدين
خفت الامور فتحت قبل انتقاله من سجن تدمر
لسجن صيدنايا
بفتره يعني قد يعني
تنقاس بالسنوات
يعني انا مثلا قبل ما ينتقل على
بالسنه خفت شوي الامور وبعدين صارت شويه
طبيعيه عاديه نظل بعض المتزمتين اخذين
موقف يعني ما بتعاطوا معه يعني
في حاله من القوقعه
لكي تنقذوا انفسكم او نفسيكم بالحقيقه
اجباريه اجباريه يعني مفروضه من الخارج
يعني مفروضه من الخارج يعني
تستقبل فقط تتلقى ولا ترسل ابدا ابدا يعني
عاديه داخل السجن يعني مثل العاده وعم
بيتعاقبوا وعم بيتعذبوا كل المسائل هذا
وعم بشارك فيها يعني ولكن كمان في العامل
الذاتي هو الخوف بعد ما
محاوله القتل امام المرحاض ايوه صار في
توجس وخوف يعني فهو كمان انكفى على نفسه
ولذلك قوقعه من طرفين يعني الخوف منهم من
ناحيه ومفروضه من الخارج من ناحيه اخرى
تمام الا من الثقب الا من الثقب الثقب
للمراقبه وليس للتواصل الانساني ولكن كان
يتم رؤيه كل عمليات الشمس والاعد التعذيب
من خلال هذا الثقب الذي
يرى من خلاله مغطيا راسه بالبطانيه
ليس من خوفا من الخارج خوفا من الداخل حتى
ما يعرف الناس انه هو شو عم بيعمل يعني
قبل ان ينفتح عليه بعض
لما يكشف لهم يعني
صار في يعني قليل من الثقه
وبصير متبادله يعني هو ايضا كشف السر لبعض
الناس داخل المهجه انه انا اراقب ما يجري
خارج المهجه وخاصه حفلات الاعدام
تخيلت ان عناصر الشرطه العسكريه ذو وجوه
مسلوخه ايه قوه سلخت هذه الوجوه كيف سلخت
لماذا اين لست ادري لكن ما اراه ان الوجوه
البديل لا تشبه وجوه باقي البشر وجوه
اهلنا واصدقائنا مسح غير بشريه هي غير
مرئيه صحيح ولكنها قطعا موجوده
كيف كنت تتعامل مع هؤلاء التعامل مع
المحقق في بدايه مجيئه الى الاعتقال وقصه
الاعتقال شيء والتعامل بعدين مع السجانه
العاديين شيء اخر السجان العاديين هو مجرد
عباره عن اله غير انسانيه
وظيفته الوحيده في هذا المكان هو انه
يعذبك ويقتلك فاي استشداء او اي
تضرع يعني محاوله الثليين مستحيله يعني
بتصيح يعني مثلا
بسموها حلاوه الروح يعني وقت بتكون تعاني
الام شديده جدا مبرحه من
تستنجد تستنجد بالله تستنجد بمحمد تستنجد
بعضهم كان مثلا مشان الله مشان حافظ اسد
على اساس انه محافظ
فهذه كان يزيد التعذيب
بمعنى وذاكرها انا بالاداء انه اسم حافظ
الاسد توسخ واطلع من تم هذا السجن
فعمليه كنا كلياتنا واعينا انه هاي عمليه
غير مجديه ولذلك اي استجداء يعني هو يعني
[موسيقى]
وازلال غير مبرر غير مبرر بس هؤلاء كانوا
يفعلون ذلك باعتقادك بحكمه وظيفتهم
العسكريه او بناء على تشف معين حقد معين
غل لاي سبب كان
يوجد من الطرفين من الطرفين من الطرفين
لديه حقد ماذا طائفي او مذهبي او طبقي
ربما
طبقي طبقي ما بتصور يعني لانه كان السجناء
مختلف الطبقات المجتمع يعني بالعكس
الاخوان المسلمين اغلبهم
ميسورين يعني مدن
بعض الاتين حضرتك ذكرت مثل عن احد الاطباء
في السجن من العساكر اللي كان عندها
حي حاله خاصه كثير وهي موجوده وحقيقيه
وكانت في جامعه حلب
بس يعني بالاساس
ممكن ان يوجد من كل التنويعات اللي حكيت
عنها
الطبيب قتل من زملاء 14 شخص اللي قتلهم
الطبيب تسبب بقتل 14 شخص لابناء دفعته كان
دفعته كلهم
بواسطه السجان يعني احيانا يسلط عليه سجان
يعني بس فيما يتعلق بالحقد يعني كان الحقد
الطائفي واضح احيانا لانه في حاله ال14
قتيله حضرتك ذكرتها بالروايه لها علاقه
بالمقدم الذي اتى الى السجن وكان تلقى
تهديدا في الخارج وبناء عليه قتل ال14
شخصا وفي حاله الطبيب
السجان او طبيب السجن الذي قتلت اثنين
فيصل غانم وقتلوا عباره كان عنده مسدس
بمجرد انه تلقى تهديدا
يتخلص يتخلص من كل من يعرفه
بسبب عقده نقص شخص
وقصه طويله عريضه يعني
لانه كان المفروض تحكي مع الطبيب نفسه
ويقول لك
هي عباره عن تخمينات يعني بس بعض الناس من
دفعته قبل ما يقتلون حكوا للاخرين انه هذا
كان معناه وهذا يبدو حاقد عم بيقتل
زملائنا او قتل زميلنا الفلاني قتل زميلنا
الفلاني فبصير عدد السينات الاخرين
عمليه تحليل وتركيب يعني بيحللوا انه هذا
السبب هو اللي خلى هذا الطبيب يسلك هذا
السلوك نتابع قليلا في لعبه المصطلحات
هنا ناتي الى ما بعرف شو منسميها يعني
التعليم او لما يقول له علم لي اياه علمني
شو يعني
علم لي نظام المهدي على النبي سجن تدمر كل
مهجاء فيه شيء اسمه شراقه نعم السقف مفتوح
سقف مفتوح مثلا لنفرض 3 امتار مترين متر
ونص بمتر حسب حجم المهجى هاي الشراقه طبعا
فيها حديد اسلاك شاهي كمان حتى حتى اذا
حدا حسين يوصل للسقف ما بحسن يطلع منها
لانه هي حديد
في على السطح حرس
على كل سطح كل ما جاء حرس مهمته يحرس
وبنفس الوقت يراقب المهجع تعاليم المعطاه
للسجناء بالمهجه بعد الساعه سته او سبعه
ممنوع الحركه
سجان اللي فوق الحرس في رئيس مهجع هو معين
من قبل السجن من السجناء يعني هو سجين بس
يعني مثلا بيختاروا واحد كان سابقا عسكري
كان مساعد اول كان كذا انه يسجل انت رئيس
ما جاء ولا يستطيع ان يرفض ان يكون رئيس
المهجع بيكون دائما محله جنب الباب
قد يكون له امتياز انه ممكن ياخذ مساحه
اكثر من غيره ننفرض 10 سم او 15 سم بالعرض
السجان بس اذا شاف واحد من السجناء بعد
الزمن المضروب او الموعد المحدد تحرك بقول
له علم لي هات
فبالليل الوحده حسب نفسيه السجان وحسب
تركيبته وحسب حقده حسب
مزاجه احيانا
وطبعا بعد ساعتين بيجي سجان تاني كمان
بعلم كمان ناس اخرين وهكذا للصبح يعني بين
السته والسته 12 ساعه بيعدي سته سجانين كل
واحد منهم ممكن يعلم في معظم ما بعلم يعني
وشو بيكون القصص القصص تاني يوم الصبح
المعلمين
لازم رئيس المهجى يعرفهم كلهم المعلمين
هدول لازم كلياتهم يطلعوا ياكلوا دولاب كل
واحد دولاب دولاب دولاب دولاب يعني
بشكل اساسي قشط مراوح الدبابات هلا في
كثير وسائل للضرب يعني حسب المتوفر بين
ايدين السجان احيانا احيانا حديده احيانا
قبل رباعي بيسموه احيانا الاغلب الاغلب
بسجن تدمر كان مزودين هن مراوح شاط
الدبابات واعتقد هنا ياتي دور الفدائيين
في هذا ودعني اسالك عن معنى ذلك بعد
الفاصل شكرا لوجودك معنا مجددا استاذ
مصطفى مشاهدينا ومتابعينا الكرام فاصل
قصير قبل ان نتابع في هذه الحلقه من
الذاكره السياسيه مع مصطفى خليفه الروائيه
والمعتقل السياسيه السوريه السابق
في بعض
مساجين يعني
اما انتحر نتيجه وصوله الى نقطه معهد في
يستمروا بالواقع اللي موجود فيه حاليا او
الجن
اهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا الكرام ومتابعينا
اينما كنتم نتابع واياكم في الذاكره
السياسيه في هذه الحلقه مع مصطفى خليفه
المعتقل السياسي السوري السابق والروائي
الشهير اهلا بكم معنا استاذ مصطفى مره
جديده كنت سالتك قبل الفاصل عن موضوع
الفدائيين ما كان دورهم تحديدا في داخل
المعتقل
الفدائيين لعبوا دور كثير كبير في انقاذ
حياه عشرات او مئات او ممكن يكون الاف
الناس كيف بالعام هن عباره عن مجموعه من
الشباب المتدين ايوه لم يكن من غير
متدينين فدائيين يعني هون بتلعب مساله
الايمان
دور كثير كبير
الامام بالله
والقضاء والقدر بيعرف انه يعني هو مؤمن
انه
يعني ان لن يصيبه الا كتب الله له يعني
اكثر من عامل يعني بس الايمان بيلعب دور
يعني بالموضوع يعني
المعلمين داخل المهجع
المعلمين لهم دورين اللي بدهم
يتعاقبوا سواء كان المعاقب مريض او كبير
بالعمر شيخ
الجسم ضعيف قد
يتاذى او قد يتوفى نتيجه تعذيبهم مثلا
دولاب بده يطلع ياكلوا 200 كرباج يعني ليس
يعني شيئا سهلا
فهذول مهمتهم هو
الحلول محل المعلم فالسجان ما بيعرف هو
علم مين قال له رئيس المهجى علم فلان
بيعرف انه هو علم 12 شخص هذول لازم الصبح
يطلعوا
فبيطلعوا الفدائيين على الاغلب بيطلع هل
هي كانت بين
المسجد او المعتقلين المعتقلين انفسهم
القوقعه التي دخلت فيها في داخل السجن
لانه كما تذكر في روايتك انك كنت بين
سندان القمع والظلم من قبل السجان ومطرقه
التشدد والتزمت من قبل المعتقلين زملائك
هل كان بها كروايه
حتى دراميه اضيف اليها الكثير من التوابل
اذا صح التعبير
بهدف الصنعه الروائيه او كانت في كلها او
معظمها على الاقل حقيقيه مئه بالمئه
صنع روايه نهائيا لا اكثر من هيك انا بدي
اقول هلا بعد هالفتره الزمنيه الطويله نحن
واقعنا اسوا بعد وقال سياسي بسوريا هيك
وقعنا بين مطرقه النظام وسندان التطرف
استاذ مصطفى اسمح لي اسالك يعني كل الفتره
التي عشتها كانت عباره عن كثيره ولكن ايها
كان الاقصى عليك هل التعذيب الجسدي بشكل
شخصي او التعذيب النفسي او ما كنت تراه
مكان يحصل لبعض زملائك في داخل المعتقل
حقيقه لا يمكن يعني الحديث عن شغله محدده
واعتبارها هذا يعني
على المستوى الشخصي انا مرضت داخل
المعتقل بسجن تدمر يعني وصلت الى تقريبا
لا استطيع الحركه
نفيس التعذيب والكذا العمود الفقري كان
مضروب يعني كنت راح انشل يعني
فكنت عالي على الاخرين
بحمامي باكله بشربه
بغسيلي بهذه
لمده تقريبا سنه ونص بعدين
[موسيقى]
فكان في نسبه معينه يعني داخل السجناء
حالتين اساسيتين
ممن ذكرتهما في ذكرتهما في الروايه حضرتك
فيما يتعلق بنسيم الذي ايضا
انتحر لاحقا يعني بعد خروجه من السجن
والحاله الاخرى ايضا ممن جن لم يستطع
التحمل التحمل الواقع هذا الموجود وهذا
كان يحصل بسبب اساسي هو رؤيه ماسي الاخرين
مثل رجل كبير السن الذين اعدموا ثلاثه من
ابنائه الشباب
يعني اللي بجن انا يعني كنت اقول لهم صار
نقاش طويل عريض بين
السجناء يعني بيني وبين رفقاتي داخل السجن
يعني يعني
وين بيكون شخص كثير مرهف الاحساس وكثير
رقيق وكثير حساس وشاعر ما قادر يتحمل على
هذا الواقع
فكنت اللي بجنوا هن الاكثر ذكائنا ولا
اكثر حساسيه والاكثر رقه
[ضحك]
منه
بعد السجن حتى بعد السجن يبقى يعني بدك
فتره زمنيه طويله حسب الحياه اللي بتعيشها
بعد السجن يعني اذا كنت ضمن وسط متفهم
واحتضنها
وتدرج ممكن ان يخرجك شيئا فشيئا من هذه
القوقعه ممكن
سجنوا حالهم بالبيت بيت اهله مثلا يعني
مثل كانه بيعتادوا على ما كانوا عليه قدره
على التاقلم مع الناس مع الحياه
يمكن يبدو غريب شوي بس هل تشتاق بين قوسين
الى يعني ولو
اشتاق للسجن نعم اشتاق للسجن في بعض
الحالات اشتاق للناس اللي كانوا معي
بالسجن في بعض الحالات
عايش معهم اكثر مما عشت مع اخوي
انك تعيش مع شخص عشر سنوات 12 سنه متواصله
24 ساعه من 24 ساعه ايوه دقيقه بدقيقه
تتقاسموا كل شيء تتقاسم الهموم والاحزان
بيعرف عنك وبيعرف عن عيلتك وبيعرف وبتعرف
عنه وبتعرف عن عيلته وبتعرف تفاصيل كلها
يعني تقريبا مثل نوع من انواع
التوحد يعني
قبل شويه قلت لك يعني وفي نبل
يعني في نبل هلا بكل انسان في جانب منه
نبيل يعني ايوه بس الظروف القاسيه هاي
يبدو بتنمي حاله النبل والايثار والغيريه
عن بعض الناس يعني
فبتشوف قلت لك كمل النبل والايثار
والغيريه اللي شفتها بالسجن من قبل
المساجين لم اراها في مكان اخر ربما بصير
في كمان ايضا تعود على عادات جديده وممكن
ممكن ممكن ايه وفي يعني الاحتكاك
والنقاشات والهذا كله بتفتح الذهن وبتفتح
الروح حتى لو كانت احلام يقظه يعني
وقت توصل لدرجه التفاهه الحياه
هاي كمان مثلا كتير ثوره انه حياتي هي
عباره عن شغله تافهه لا تستاهل ان انت
تتعلق فيها وتقاتل مش انا يعني
تسقط قيمه الاشياء الماديه في عينيك
في لحظه معينه اثرت بكثيرا عند قراءه
الروايه هي قصه الرجل الكبير السن الذي
اعدم ثلاثه من ابنائه لمعرفته وهو معه
معهم في داخل السجن وفي اللحظه التي كانوا
يعدمون فيها وكان يعني
ينتحب كان يبكي كان متاثرا بشده كانت اكثر
اللحظات صراحه التي اثرت في شخصيا
بكل الناس يعني وهي قصه حقيقيه يعني واسم
القاضي يعني ليس حكم على يعني هو حوالي
يفدي واحد من ولاده اللي هو اخر ولاده
يعني قال له اعدلنا جميعا ولكن
في البدايه وافقوا يعني ما حدا بيعرفه
من ابنائه 65 70 سنه واعدم
كان الرجل كبير السن يريد ان يبقي على
الصغير كي يتزوج لان الاخرين متزوجان هو
حكم بسوريا مثل بيحكوا بسوريا يعني ما
خلفوا ومن خلف ما مات
فبده ابنه صغير كمان مشان لا ينقطع ذكره
بده يطلع على الحياه مره ثانيه ويجوز مره
ثانيه ويخلف
لانه اللي خلاك
قصه كانت كتير مؤثره
داخل السجن يعني
جدا صحيح جدا داخل السجن وخارجه وستعيش
بحكم سطوري روايتك يعني دائما ان شاء الله
لكي تحيي هذه الوقائع المريره والماساويه
التي عيشتها مع الكثير الكثير من
المعتقلين نتابع بعض الفاصل في البودكاست
ولكن نختم هذه الحلقه التلفزيونيه الان
استاذ مصطفى شكرا بوجودك معنا مجددا
وقراءه مقطع جديد من قبلك شخصيا حصريا
لبودكاست العربيه شكرا لكم متابعينا
ومشاهدينا الكرام ولقائنا يتجدد
التليفزيونيا الاسبوع المقبل اما الان
فالى البودكاست بودكاست العربيه الى
اللقاء يضلوا بالسجن حتى يعني ممكن عشر
سنين ممكن عشر سنين
كل من داخل هذا المهجع محكوم بالبراءه
[موسيقى]